good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Tuesday that feels like a Monday but it
also feels like a Friday because we're
celebrating the fact that Yom Kippur is
behind us 365 days till the next one hey
Jax
I'm trying to calculate your weekday
math which do you agree is what we do it
doesn't feel like a Friday but it does
feel like a Tuesday though it is
um Monday no it feels like a Monday but
it's that's what I said you're not
you're not feeling like celebratory
Vibes no because I'm stressed to the
teeth over here oh my God she's stressed
to the teeth what's going on I just have
so much going on there's just so much
going on in my house mother of two book
launch homeowner I get it personal
professional Harry's under the weather
it's just oh my God it's just there's a
lot going on so no it doesn't feel like
a Friday it feels like a Monday e Monday
I'm not gonna lie but then it brings me
Solace to know that it's Tuesday and so
what Yom Kippur taketh away food and
giveth in a short week
we have not even spoken since the fast
we both were off our phone for 25 hours
and we didn't even talk last night when
we could turn our phones back on so
Jackie how was your fast my fast was
okay so I didn't know what I was gonna
do being a breastfeeding mama and I was
also like reading some stuff and it's
like there are varying degrees of
breastfeeding like your child could be
older and also having like solid food
and do breasts yeah of course so it's
like are you the only one who's
dependent your child is dependent on you
for food you're just primary care
physician
so I decided that I was going to
incorporate liquids into my day I wasn't
going to wait till I was on death's door
like I was just gonna drink water and
electrolytes throughout the day and no
food and so that's what I did and it was
okay by the end I was you know ravenous
but really it made me realize it's the
lack of water that
is the Ruiner yeah it's really hard
because I was I was relatively stable
throughout the day considering because I
was Juliana drinking a lot of water of
course actually not that much I probably
drank two water bottles like Poland
Spring bottles total that's a lot uh the
water is really tough because your
breath becomes so fragrantly disgusting
and it makes you just like of course
you're hungry but you have this natural
instinct to like swoosh some water
around your mouth to get rid of that
nasty smell and you can't so that sounds
like a lovely Yom Kippur like a
manageable one it was manageable yeah
and I think my Supply was okay though I
did pump this morning and I got less
than I usually get when I pump in the
mornings but I'm gonna have some soup
today which always helps restock Supply
what did you eat at 7 30 last night a
bagel and a half
a bagel and a half one half had tuna one
half had cream cheese and lox and then I
went for the other half my dessert Bagel
cinnamon raisin with jelly that's so you
so me I love it I hosted the breakfast
at my house and I almost like I kind of
forgot that you were there because I got
cinnamon raisin and jelly and I just
figured like somebody would eat it but I
didn't realize that's like your order
for my dessert Bagel but never for my
Savory bake of course and never the
twain shall meet I once I go sweet I
cannot go back to Savory I know I had uh
four halves which equals two Bagels I
was so hungry the whole day I really
um was like on the verge of fainting
like I have low blood pressure or sugar
I can never remember which one so I like
when I stand up too fast like I usually
get lightheaded but it's not a big deal
but when I have no food like I was
literally standing in my house I
crouched over my eyes like
willing the blood to rush back to or
whatever happens like willing the blood
to rush back to my head it was a really
hard day for me and I know like nobody
wants to hear because I'm on performance
enhancing drugs but like I still feel as
though like I endured the fast I feel
like I Can Begin this year on a good
level like knowing I suffered yesterday
tabula rasa yeah it was really hard for
me food is just like and you know this
happens to me every year where I just I
in that moment when I'm dying of hunger
I just remember like I have free will
every other day of the year like eat
when you want to eat like I was just
thinking I'm like I don't need enough I
don't eat enough I don't enjoy it did it
make you want to go off of something
kind of I'm like I'm taking for granted
this Freedom this liberte whenever I'm
fasting not yesterday because I was
drinking it really makes me appreciate a
glass of ice cold water
you know like it makes me romanticize
ice water any liquid like even just in
the class of apple juice over ice sound
good no like a Snapple over ice sounds
good sample's just not hydrating you
can't guzzle it I know what you mean
though like I was thinking yesterday
like when was the last time I just like
sat and ate a donut like I don't enjoy
the fruit of of life's you know
offerings I don't enjoy it enough and
yesterday was like really
indicative of that I had a realization
that I really need to enjoy food more
well you used to yeah no I had you know
28 good years of enjoying everything
life had to offer yeah
and but still I think I think it just
you hit a place because this is not
maturity this is not new turdy who's
talking like this who wants to go back I
know no but Jackie I like I was deprived
and I saw life it's like when you're in
a desert like you start thinking you
know all different things like I was
literally having a mirage like I was not
okay that you wanted to be old turdy
again yeah like gotta be fat again
okay well maybe she'll come to her
senses maybe she won't we'll see maybe
these are her senses now let's talk
about the timing of Yom Kippur it
couldn't have been worse for our
business
right but you know what
it was nice to just have a day for
ourselves to enjoy the news you know
what I mean that's true run and plug and
we did do an Instagram live but it's
like yeah I get to come on today and and
I feel like I'm less like hyper about it
yeah like less erratic I also think yeah
my feelings on Travis and Taylor are
extremely complex and I'm kind of glad
like the next morning I didn't just like
spout some [__] like I you know
everybody knows if you listen to
Friday's episode like this maybe it's
not necessarily like what I wanted
yeah but I think it was good that you
had time to ruminate with the news even
if you still want to right about some
[__] today like
it's more at least it will have been
well thought out yeah exactly so that's
obviously the big news of the day but
you know what else we didn't use our
phones for 25 hours and oh when I tell
you it was such a joy and I hate to be
one of those people that's like uh phone
no you're not I have I have the same
experience but the reason why it was
mostly Joy's because I only really
talked to our family throughout the day
and like knowing you guys weren't on
your phones either like I wasn't missing
anything but throughout the day like I'm
constantly picking up my phone like
what's going on in the family chat I'm
constantly taking pictures and sending
them to the family and like since we
were all offline I didn't have the urge
to do that at all and usually like my
itch to pick up my phone is so much
greater than it was yesterday and I
think that's why we didn't even talk
last night because I was like phone get
the [__] away from me hoe I had the
exact same experience and I hate to
sound like one of those girls yeah but
the night uh like so the fast is 25
hours so at 6 30 you stop eating and you
stop using like Electronics so I turned
my phone off at 6 30 and I will say like
that night I did reach for it like two
times like just an instinct to be like
oh what's going on hey you know is my
Tick Tock blowing up and then and I was
like oh this is going to be really
difficult for me and then the next day I
don't think I thought about my phone
once and even when everybody came over
everybody got to my house at like 6 30
and we we chilled for an hour before we
ate I didn't run I ran to eat I did not
run to
um check my phone and I don't think I
checked my phone till like an hour after
I could it was such a delight and then
me and Ben were talking about how like
you know if we were being the good
observant Jews that we should be we
would do that every Friday night to
Saturday night you know just take
Shabbat to be with family and be off of
phones and honestly it's like such a
nice way to live I would love to
incorporate it into my life somehow but
like I don't know if it's like feasible
at this current Junction but it really
did make me like appreciative of that
time without my phone me too I Olivia
and I both we didn't run to turn them
back on when the fast was over and then
last night I was just like you are toxic
I did so much like handwriting while uh
the fact because I write down every time
I breastfeed so that I know how much
before the next one like which boob I'm
on so I just like did that with a pen
and paper beside my bed I made a grocery
list for Zach and it was literally so
gorgeous
you have some of the most beautiful pen
there's not I'm not a jealous person and
you know after yesterday being in school
realizing you know you shouldn't be
envious you shouldn't be greedy like all
these things I'm really not and actually
that's not true I'm actually an
extremely jealous person but not of you
let me just say that because I'm happy
for you but your penmanship your
penmanship is something I deeply Envy
it's so gorgeous it's like a typewriter
thank you my it's been on fleek
especially since I signed 1500 book
plates my hand like that muscle is back
in Action that indentation in my ring
finger is dented once again so I wrote
him a list and it was so gorgeous I
wanted to take a picture of it and post
it to my story but you cut it but I
couldn't I signed so many book plates I
got them all done yesterday which I'm so
excited about if you want a signed copy
of the camera and the counselor head
over to talk shop live it's no extra
cost it's a book plate with your girlie
signature and I just want you to know
like not a signature was out of place I
took away ones that there were about
five that did not make the cut you had a
high bar for excellence yeah I did so
talk shop live but you can get Cambrian
counselor everywhere it comes out in
like 14 days that's true it's so crazy
we're not being nearly as annoying as we
should be no not at all and I keep
meaning to bring the book upstairs but
like Harry won't let it go from his
clutches oh yeah you need to do like
some visual aids girlfriend I do need to
do some visual aids but you guys my
debut novel just kidding children's book
comes out but same thing you know to the
children it's a novel no and if you have
read the book which I have and like you
know the actual plot you know it's that
sophisticated it's that of a novella
like it really is of a novella now
what's the difference between a novel
and a novella one's a female novel or is
Novella a book in Spanish because that's
what it sounds like
yeah
but Novella is like an English word
correct um no I don't think it's English
could be loud no I think it is it could
be Latin
Novella is a short novel or long short
story oh so it's like a shorter book so
it's a novella camber encounter is a
novella it's a novella and you can get
that Novella anywhere that you pre-order
your books including Kindle it's going
to be on e-readers oh that's where I'll
be purchasing I already have my Amazon
Prime I literally sent Amazon Prime
order like pre-orders to my in-laws to
me like to five different people oh my
God Queen thank you of course so yeah
I'm working on a lot of stuff for female
writers but it was nice to have to take
the 25 hours to not be able to be on
email but I was doing the book plate
anyway
um and that's the only thing about the
phone where it was like it was really
nice to be offline but like you can't
work you can only be so productive
without your phone yeah no especially
when you do what we do when you do what
we do so it was really nice to have the
day off in its entirety even the day off
I think the Travis Kelsey Taylor Swift
thing was a perfect thing to because
that's like the height of what we do and
the height of Pop Culture I'm like we
had to detach from it no and I think it
shows our strength and our commitment to
our faith yes so true we're so committed
and to be honest the timing was pretty
good because by the time we had to shut
our phones off like mostly everything
had happened not the walk back backstage
I know I know but we got like that the
convertible
that's our first story of course correct
our first story is the whole Sunday Saga
oh Sunday night in Kansas City at
rocking the stage at Arrowhead it kind
of felt like everyone was waiting all
day for Sunday night right yeah yeah and
are we going to talk about Usher as a
Super Bowl performance Football news and
we actually have a third Football news
I'll move things around so it's the top
three are football even though the third
story is like so not the third out of
five I understand but just for like you
know organizational purposes and
segway's sake I love a Segway I
um I feel like this happens every year
but like it's getting like a little bit
more um like exciting each time like
we're getting so into football like
remember last season I know with the
Niners like it's really a great time to
be a football fan which is us now us now
yeah and I like that work just kind of
team agnostic I know like we have a lot
of love for the Niners and my family we
love the Cowboys but I could I could
literally but I'm like I'm polyamorous
when it comes to football teams we're
like totally agnostic like whenever
there's a game on like I can decide
which team I want to root for based on a
Litany of things like are any
celebrities dating any of the players
like is there like a interesting pop
culture moment related to a certain team
because that's like how I'll decide who
I want to win is there a toaster wife is
there a toaster wife
um also if it's like a New York team
there's like three different ones like
I'm just more inclined to root for that
one yeah
it's exciting oh and I'm trying I think
I'm gonna go to the Jets game this
weekend because the Chiefs are playing
the Jets this weekend now I doubt Taylor
will be there yeah because she will get
she wouldn't be able to go like she'll
get mobbed she had the element of
surprise on her side last time so she
was able to come in through the popcorn
cart but I still do want to go you
should go you were saying before yeah
like I love Aaron Rodgers in his time of
need yeah I love Aaron too I'm good guys
they did uh you know they do a segment
called buddy of nuts yes of course where
they just like you know
talk about random things in life like
things people did to them that week or
just like different concepts that they
think are not and Josh had a really
funny one he's like what's with the name
Aaron
like the two A's like Aaron Alex was an
amazing call like why do you spell Aaron
that way it's so true and not that it
was ever even in my top 10 of names but
somewhere in the family floated the name
to me as like because it's biblical so I
think like we are constantly looking
back at the homage for inspiration yeah
and so I'm sure it came across our desk
when we were naming some of your kids or
maybe Levi like yeah it was floating my
way but it wasn't for me Aaron Aaron
oh no that they said it on the episode
that I was on that's why I know it not
that I like I do listen to most of their
episodes but no that's Chinese like I'm
a good guy's number one fan such a good
call yeah it is a nice name but when you
think about it too hard it hurts your
brain it's it's that's exactly yeah
because it's a nice I feel like every I
haven't met like a lot of errands but
those that are named that are very like
they really live up to the name it's
like a it feels like it's a tall guy's
name like it's it's a strong name yeah
but it also reminds me of Aaron Carter
oh that's funny
uh I hadn't thought I hadn't made the
connection well who's the first Aaron in
your mind
like this week Rogers yeah but
by the way I know this is crazy
is Aaron Carter dead yeah I I I wasn't
sure either but yes and the more I think
about it yes completely forgot about
that yeah me too it's so sad
yeah I don't know who my first thought
of is we've had this conversation now
too long for me to know what my original
thought was I don't know who I would
have thought of when I was there like an
Aaron from your middle school who is who
was tooling it out with Maverick for
your love I was thinking that growing up
there was definitely somebody in my
middle school or high school with the
name Aaron Aaron is a very Middle School
name especially when you went to a
Jewish Day School oh I guess so I feel
like it's the time though like I feel
like Aaron is kind of like a 90s name
yeah no it's kind of how like we think
now like there are no small children
named Barbara
actually more I feel like it's that's a
name that's coming back but yeah okay I
meant like sure Deborah
sure
I feel like there's no grown adult's
name Aaron like just middle schoolers
who exist in that yeah
they're in a Time Warp and they can't
get out is this a universal experience
or just like a Jackson Club experience
Aaron Rodgers busted through with his
Superior strength yeah and I guess I
never really like this is such a dumb
conversation but I guess I never really
truly realized that Aaron Rodgers's name
is Aaron you know yeah he's a first
elastie the thing about names is you
can't think about them for too long oh
my God I completely agree honestly my
name is like low-key weird no yes
Claudia is through and through a Latin
name like any time I've gotten into an
Uber or like made a conversation with
the taxi driver they always ask me like
people who don't know me always ask me
if I'm Latin they always think I speak
Spanish they start speaking to me in
Spanish and thankfully I do speak a
little Spanish but not because it's my
native tongue well my name is French
Jacqueline yeah but like your name's
Jackie
I'm French
anybody who doesn't know me thinks that
I'm Spanish
why is that my name maybe there's a
Latin La turia running around and then
just like an Australian turkey don't get
me started on the Latin translation of
Claudia what lame
that's just her fault if the shoe fits
yeah I don't feel like the name fits me
I think it does
let me know do you think my name fits me
sound off in the comments like you are
such a Jackie it's wild that's kind of
rude
why I don't know
I love your name really yeah I love your
name you do yeah I feel like of all the
names in our family like I got the worst
one what no I feel like Alden we have
amazing names in our family our mom
crushed it but I feel like everyone's
name is a little more unique than mine
but I've always taken Solace and the
fact that yeah Jackie was like kind of
common especially when the when I was
named you know there's a lot of Jackie's
born in 1992 but I'm Jackie O so
everyone else can [__] off okay I I
don't disagree that your name is the
least unique but mine is I think the
most unique perhaps a little too unique
I think at the time of naming Margo was
the most unique now it's quite common I
just say I thank God for Claudia
Schiffer like I just remember like being
really proud of her growing up because
like everybody has a celebrity with
their name who like you know made the
name famous or whatever and mine
happened to be someone extremely
fabulous yeah
and I always have Jackie O so right so
we're in good company girly we are by
the way have you noticed that like
our toastism
we have so many isms but yargarlies or
just like putting the a instead of an
like a vowel has really caught on I've
been seeing it everywhere really yes
girly swirly garlic I've been seeing it
like all over popular culture that's so
heartwarming like and sometimes things
we say become really popular but we
didn't invent them maybe we you know
helped the most popular eyes but we did
not invent like certain like phrases
that went super super viral but like
Yara garlays is like a toastism through
like we invented it you're welcome
you're welcome that's where it comes
from and just wait and that comes from
yeah ugly yeah to see it take on a life
of its own I feel very proud I didn't
know that it was out there in that way
it's it's just it's a Grassroots
movement but like it's taking on
momentum it's so fun it's hilarious yeah
so
so I think it's time I just wanted to
make one content note because I watched
a lot of TV
over the hog and I watched that show
girl meets Farm
and and it was very good cooking
VPC VGC very good cooking I was inspired
to make a few things though I have
absolutely no time on my hands so I
don't know when I think I'm making an
apple pie but I might give it a shot ugh
I love apple pie like I was watching her
and I was like What if I just [__]
made a pie I mean Charlie would be
starving the whole time in the bathroom
free will like you could just make a pie
no no but like what about Charlie no I
know but like you must be held I know
I'm gonna make a pie like I'm gonna
carve out the time you should I'm gonna
because that Sparks joy and you have
free will and I think it's important
that we never forget that amen
amen sella without further Ado here are
the past five stories that you
absolutely need to know today and I mean
that with every fiber of my being and
the fast five stories that you
absolutely need to know today where she
means that with every fiber of her being
is brought to you by Pillsbury so so
many simple recipes can be made with
Pillsbury crescent rolls and they can be
added into your weeknight dinner
rotation making dinner like on a working
day is just not exciting it's not fun
and it's like more work than it should
be and I can only imagine like having
kids it's just like why is it so hard
Pillsbury Crescent understands that
dilemma and they are here to help busy
working moms kid pleasing dinners are
easier than you think they have recipes
that won't take all night you're
basically just filling Pillsbury
crescents with delicious ingredients
that transform crescents from a side
dish to a main dish that's what I'm
gonna make
yeah by the way like couldn't be easy
yeah this is a perfect solution for what
I just said I feel like we are always
like talking about problems here at the
toast we're very like infrequently just
giving Solutions I just I feel like I'm
more of a complainer and Pillsbury heard
us and they said we got you like I think
it's so delicious to roll up a Pillsbury
Crescent with like a little tomato sauce
and some mozzarella a little crescent
pizza and it's like I want I wanted to
cook at home but I don't have a million
hours to do so right and of course you
could take to the next level if you you
know can eat this like add a little
pepperoni then it's a hearty protein
filled meal obviously we can't do that
but still a pizza Crescent sounds very
good so they have so many easy recipes
to please your picky eaters and then
just move on with your evening so you
can find Pillsbury in the daily aisle
it's Dairy Isle dinner prep in 30
minutes or less and it's picky eater
pleasing today's episode is also brought
to you by Caraway caraway's nonstick
kitchenware makes cooking a breeze and
cleaned up easier than ever it's back to
school made easy with so many
collections of their internet famous
kitchenware to explore there's a a
Caraway for every kind of cook it's a
non-toxic chemical free ceramic coating
which means that you can be food can be
prepared with peace of mind that know
how to pronounce chemical will leach
into your healthy ingredients and it's
an important time for us to send this
message because it's chilly season it's
been raining in New York for five days
straight we made a chili four days ago
and I've eaten nothing else but that and
we made it in our Dutch oven from
Caraway so perfect nothing burned so
easy to clean it's one dish I love a one
pot dish just like Joanna gains I love
it one pot dish oopd every set comes in
a various modern Shades to fit with any
design aesthetic and it includes easy
access storage solutions to keep the
kitchen tidy and now introducing
caraway's prep set it's 10 essential
knives and utensils designed for
chopping better prepping cleaner and
storing easier I have to say Caraway is
one of those brands at this point
anytime they release a product like I
trust you I'm purchasing it I'm not I
don't have amazing kitchenware in my
house so I'm very slowly converting
everything over to Caraway yep I got
targeted ads for their new Cutlery
kitchenware and I'm influenced I'm
influenced I'm going to use coatost
visit carawayhome.com the toast you're
not using Code toast oh [__] to take
advantage of this limited time offer for
10 off your next purchase the deal is
exclusive for our listeners so visit
carawayhome.com the toast or just use
code the toast at checkout Caraway
non-toxic cookware made Modern today's
episode is also brought to you by Athena
Club so the blade on my old razor used
to get all goopy after a few uses but I
love the water activated serum on Athena
club's razors there's just enough of it
to soothe while shaving but it never
gets gunky on the blade our old Racers
used to always fall off the holder on
meditation we ever wake in the middle of
the night because your razor fell off
the shower and made like a clanking and
you think you're being robbed has
happened to me so many times since I
switched to Athena club which I feel
like is now like three or four months
I have literally never woken up in a
fright in the middle of the night
anymore the magnetic hook that comes
with the razors is genius it keeps our
razors from falling every time we open
the shower so it's designed with
built-in skin guards to help prevent
razor burn while being gentle on curves
plus the razor blade is surrounded by a
water activated Serum with shea butter
and hyaluronic acid which is a holy
grail for skin care the best part is
that the razor kit is only ten dollars
it comes with two blade heads a magnetic
hook for shower storage and your choice
of handle color the handle color options
are so cute but they even have black and
white razors for all you minimalists
mine is pink it's so cute I've been in
shaving overdrive recently not only
because it was summer like I was showing
my legs but I'm on my hair regrowth
Journey so I'm taking lots of vitamins
and pills for my actual hair and that's
made my legs and armpits like so hairy
I'm shaving like multiple times a week
now and I need a razor that can handle
it and that's Athena Club so switch to
the better razor and show your skin that
you care with Athena Club get started
today by shopping in store at Target
stores nationwide head to the Shaving
aisle to find the Razor kit the cloud
shave foam the wax strips the razor
refills everything you could possibly
need for your shaving needs Athena Club
has you covered at Target
thank you Claudia M you're welcome our
first story oh Sunday night Taylor Swift
was spotted at the Kansas City Chiefs
game while Travis Kelsey rocked the
stage at Arrowhead Taylor was
Taylor was sitting in a box with Mama
Kelsey after the game they were the two
were spotted together walking backstage
they went to an after party where
sources say they had a great time and
then they drove somewhere together in
the convertible yeah let's let's walk
through the beginning let's start at the
very very beginning there were rumors
had posted a couple girls on our
Facebook group said like their moms live
in Kansas and local PD had gotten you
know they had to set up for Taylor so it
slowly got out and when I tell you I did
not believe a single word of it until I
saw a picture of that girl sitting in a
box next to his mother I was so shocked
and I don't know if it was because I was
in denial or I like and listen to
Friday's episode I really did not
believe that these two were dating I
thought he was so thirsty clout chasing
like globbing onto you know the press
that he got from bringing up her
friendship bracelet like I just didn't
believe it so the actual I turned down
the game I didn't believe it but I still
watched just in case you know oh and
major men are update you know I switched
to sling TV I'm trying out all these
different I know everyone's sick of
hearing about my cable news but I just I
switched to sling TV and I just have to
say it was perfect I watched the game so
I put it on I'm like mindlessly they're
what they're putting in some other game
like the Ravens or whatever I'm like get
with the program get with the program
yeah that's the thing about football
there's like a lot of games at once
everywhere all at once and then even
with the Chiefs game that they
eventually switched to after like the
second half they switched to another
game because the chiefs were like
beating the other team so bad that like
it wasn't even worth watching so they
put on a game that was like a good
competition but like we needed to see
Taylor and we didn't get to see her but
you saw her a bit and the fans got
photos and but it's a channel I think
it's like with red zone where if you
just want to watch the one game
RedZone has four different boxes on at
once and they'll like go to one game for
a little bit amount of time but then
they'll show you all four honestly
Shapiro is always watching RedZone he
loves RedZone I think it's like crap who
wants to watch four [__] games at
once and if you're looking for one game
you have to like squint into one of the
corners every time I get invested in
football and I try to watch the game
that I'm looking for it's so difficult
well so you know I them sensing a theme
here because I've been hearing that men
like to watch like a lot of games at
once and you need like multiple TVs and
now I'm understanding that's why they
watch on their phone they have Red Zone
up four screens they've got a TV in the
other room and
it's like debilitating because I was
hanging out with a but we were with a
bunch of couples on Sunday and like the
husbands wanted to come but they were
like are they are going to be all the
games up I'm like this isn't a sports
bar no and now I always thought it was
psychotic that Olivia ashrae has two TVs
in her backyard and she's like no
Shapiro needs to watch two games at once
like oh my God that's insane
I can't imagine like seriously caring
about anything that much but okay no I
just always thought there was like one
football game like last week when the
Cowboys were on is that my husband was
saying we couldn't watch it the
Shapiro's because Shapiro won't watch
one game at a time I'm like what do you
mean no it says so many games at once I
called Olivia I'm like can we watch one
game the Cowboys team at your house and
she was like no he won't no it's tearing
families apart I had no idea this was
such a thing like why like and I think
this is what's dividing people you know
what I mean like if there was one game
that we could all focus on and then we
were like I think that's why the
playoffs are so exciting because there's
only two three games a week and
everybody's watching those ones got it I
guess if we did one at a time the
playoffs would happen every three years
right so they finally switched the
coverage from that Ravens game to the
Chiefs game and before they showed a
single player before they showed a
single MC they showed Taylor like they
milked this for what it's worth the NFL
ESPN Bleacher Report everybody was
posting on social media free social
media manager for a sports team was
working overtime on Sunday making Swifty
related content the NFL's new social
media bios is NFL Taylor's version like
everyone's being thirsty it's so crazy
like the NFL is this billion dollar
brand like it is the it is arguably one
of the biggest media brands in this
country and the way they all just like
bend the knee and like are thirsty for
Taylor like her power really
is crazy and just seeing it happen like
that all in one day like in a couple of
hours it was really crazy yeah it was
fun and a United Nation it did I think I
read somewhere that uh that NFL ratings
went up 60 for
um young female adults that's funny and
Travis Kelsey got 300 000 followers yeah
so
I knew everyone's saying like Claudia
like are you gonna eat your words like I
was wrong I I really believed in my
heart that like he was being thirsty and
like right we were wrong about not
believing that they were together but do
you want to eat your words or maybe
amend how you feel about them being
together now well now that I've now that
they are together like I'm a fan of
Taylor therefore I want her to be happy
so I'm on board like 100 and there's so
many benefits to her being in a
relationship like this like her
relationships in the past have been so
private to the point where it's like
actually boring to follow them like we
get nothing we get crumbs this is so
public it's so American you know she's
really America's sweetheart and so is he
and like I feel like we never get that
we never get like the two obvious people
together like everybody's always being
creative you know yeah and I mean what's
more American than football football and
pop music like and she's it's just it's
perfect like it really it makes a lot of
sense and we love things that make sense
here
I do and I stand by the fact that like
in recent months like Travis's Behavior
like has been annoying and thirsty like
I I stand by that
um
but Taylor seems to be into it
yeah it's before I am into it it's a
nice change of pace I was looking at the
pictures
and videos and she just looks like she
was having so much fun and I was like
when you're at the height of your career
she's been working so hard like why not
just have some fun and I just I believe
that this is like a real relationship in
the sense that it's not a fake PR
because she doesn't do that but I don't
think it's an incredibly serious
relationship or will turn into a serious
relationship I think it's just a bit of
fun and it's like on the one hand she's
so private I don't want my stuff out
there but on the other hand it's like
why not just have a day at the football
game and go balls to the walls and send
the country haywire and have some fun I
completely agree and I want to go back
to what you just said about PR because I
need to speak to everyone directly
I saw a bunch of tick tocks being made
about this people posting on social like
Taylor's doing this because she's such a
good friend to Sophie Turner that she
wanted to take you know some of the heat
away from Stampy and Joe's divorce and
put it on her and make herself a
spectacle for the next week so that
nobody talks about Joe now let me just
say one thing
we could talk about two things at once
so that we can talk about so flawed five
things the fast five things at once that
theory is beyond flawed and I really
like every time I hear like see people
making things up like that like it
reminds me like how dumb people are like
there's no level of like critical
thinking or just like realism like get a
grip like we really think Taylor would
do that someone who is her whole life
kept her relationships private like we
know nothing about her personal life
like she would do all of that for and
her personal life is so deeply connected
to her business like she would that it
just makes no sense and that's not even
a good idea if that was what she was
doing like it wouldn't work
yeah no and it's like you're operating
under the premise that one story can
squash out every other story when like
have you looked at the front page of a
newspaper it's multiple stories yeah no
talking about multiple stories it's such
a bad call and then people are like
that's an amazing call like it's a bad
call like please don't believe that be
better than that like it's not a good
call stop saying it that's just a bad
call oh my God it was bothering me so
much I didn't see that I didn't see that
you need to hang out with me yeah AKA
not on Tick Tock I'm assuming because
all over it was honestly it was platform
agnostic you're loving the word agnostic
you know who taught me that word who
It's So Random you never just like
remember where you were when you learned
the meaning of a word oh
sure
Brian Kelly when he came on the toast I
think the first time we were like what's
your favorite Airline he's like I really
prefer to be Airline agnostic oh okay I
nodded my head and then like looked it
up afterwards got it got it but I feel
like I like I've just been saying it a
lot in the last week
oh you think like I'm copying it like
it's it's like I've just bubbled it to
the surface
that's funny I literally said it like
earlier in the show I think it said on
Friday like that's really like my word I
meant today no that's hilarious
no you guys but I cited like a personal
anecdote of how I know the word of how
you learned the word sure but you
weren't like using it he's been on the
show what six years now
no I definitely have used it like
look it up sweetie
okay this is such a dumb fight back to
back to the task at hand so I will say I
am here for it
I agree with you I don't think it's
going to be the great love of her life I
don't think it's going to be a deeply
serious or intellectually stimulating
relationship but not everything has to
be and I love this change like I think
the types of guys she's dated in the
past like are really in my opinion just
like not the vibe aesthetically
professionally like I just I didn't get
it a lot of the times and I got on board
because I love Taylor like Taylor to me
like this is just proof she's human
yeah I think she'll always like What She
Likes which is you know the more inch
like British yeah creative deep you know
type of guy but I it I'm sure she's like
recognizing you know what I just need a
break from all that let's have some fun
it was more fun than Travis Kelsey it's
so true and football is fun and it's a
good way to spend her time
he I'm sure she actually really liked
the fact that he was so publicly and
probably personally like chasing her
yeah
and it's not bad also I just like five
seconds ago I realized this entire
episode I haven't been wearing lipstick
like I just put it on I'm like so mad
we can't clip we can't clip anything
from the first I think 35 minutes we'll
see we'll see what's clip worthy sickly
you look beautiful no matter what thank
you
I'm annoyed anyway Sunday was a song
is how I feel like the whole day she
could write a whole song about oh for
sure I thought you were like using that
phrase that kids don't take check use
like it was a movie like oh my God she's
using the phrase wrong no
Ben used the phrase that one hasn't
reached me yet and I don't think it's
gonna stick no you say like last night
was a movie like when it was just like
amazing and Ben used the phrase recently
on his Instagram story and me and Margo
our ashrae were cackling about it behind
his back like
he was like it was a movie I'm like what
what was he talking about we threw a
spritz party on Friday night
um for Danielle Caroline she threw her
25th birthday and like spritzed through
it for her and Ben was like posting
pictures because it was really like a
fabulous sick party and he was like this
party was a movie I'm like oh my God
stop oh my God no but like she really
could write a whole song about just
Sunday of course and it would go a
little something like this
she should sample it honestly
yeah and talk about like what it's like
to be like dating the guy on the field
like sitting with his mom there's so
many um football terms like that can be
used
as like songwriting yeah like yeah
touchdown bench
run
Enzo tailgate End Zone bleachers now do
we think that this was their first time
hanging out because he said I invited
her to come see me rock the stage at
Arrowhead like do you think that that
she just took him up on his invitation
right or that like when he said that on
Pat McAfee he knew that she was coming
and he was like giving people you know a
little teaser
that's a great question
I don't think she would be sitting next
to his mother like on his first date but
maybe your mother's is Swifty and it's
like it's different when it's like okay
I know I mean like I'm meeting the
person's mom but like she knows who I am
that's like hard like that's tough yeah
I do feel like it was very casual I
don't think it was the first time
but it me neither yeah and you know what
now I'm gonna believe everyone who said
that they've been hanging out because
yeah it turned out that they were right
so if I'm looking back at all that stuff
I think they hung out a few times before
yeah me too I don't know if she's met
his mother maybe that was the first time
she I read it was the first time she met
Mama Kells but you know what Mama Kells
looks a lot I like Mama Swift like
they're kind of twin flame energy
they're the same [__] haircut
and it makes a lot of sense it's the
bomb cut and they're both like really
close with their mothers like they
actually probably do have a decent
amount in common besides you know just
being like attractive and famous but I
don't think they've hung out too many
times because I think once they do it'll
be over yeah of course and we just got
like so much like people were taking so
many photos of Taylor I think she took a
photo with someone in the box and she
was sitting at a table and like her
plate was there and people were just
like dying to know what she ate so
here's what was on the plate ready was
it her plate or this was not her plate
we don't know if it was you know the
Quiet Woman this is not my plate but it
probably was her plate based on like the
staging of the photo there was one
chicken tender on it a pool of um
ketchup and I think a pool of ranch
pretty good order
just yeah chicken tenders yeah like she
really is just one of us
yeah this is where I'm exiting okay the
fandom
so all in all I will say
I was wrong I'm a grown enough woman to
admit that especially after Yom Kippur
it's so important to know when you were
wrong I was wrong
I'm getting on board I am on board
it was a lot and honestly like his
behavior was like a little nuts and
that's what turned me off to it but if
Taylor's here for it so am I but now and
not in hindsight do you find the
behavior like a little cute knowing like
oh
they're actually a little thing and he's
like going on National Television like
proclaiming like how much he's into her
I mean I have to imagine that now
everything he's done and said publicly
was
Taylor approved which makes it better
for sure yeah oh let's talk about the
convertible they left the stadium the
game they like walked out together
somebody took a video of them inside the
getaway car when he was like done with
the game done with his interviews he put
on a fresh outfit went out to celebrate
because they won by 40 points it was
actually one of the least interesting
football games I've ever seen in my life
um
they walked out together that video of
them like literally people were just
standing in the hallway staring like it
was actually weird and then they got
into like this old retro maroon
convertible it was giving maroon and
they drove off he was giving getaway car
yeah of course of course of course and
there's a video of her
um he's pulling out of the stadium
parking lot she like covers her hands
with her eyes and she just like is like
geeking out I don't know what about but
like she it was just like too much for
her honestly like I get it and they
drove to this private party they said I
read actually conflicting reports it
said Travis rented out a restaurant for
everyone
to celebrate the win of the game like
the whole staff and crew and whatever
and then I also read that like Taylor
paid the tab for everybody so like which
was it I feel like it was him me too
it's his home turn that's how it should
that's what I hope it was like yeah that
he did made it nice for her but I also
could see him like that's what they do
after a win he's like the king of Kansas
City what if they had lost like do you
think he had already booked the
restaurant
I think the restaurant's on standby it
might be like their go-to place for a
win yeah yeah perhaps
so okay so then they went to the after
party in the convertible it's yeah I
believe that's where they went it's
Teenage Dream no it's giving fantasy
like this isn't real so to see somebody
like actually out here living a fantasy
like you have no choice really to be
happy and it's the girl who's been
dreaming of a fantasy her whole life
who's been like it's so fantastic
she's been writing songs like about
moments like these and how she's like
never experienced them yeah and all
she's wanted to be is like the girl
dating the football star like she is now
that's what I'm saying like this is a
song that you will write about what it
is
no it's a song it's also a movie
it is a movie honestly even though
there's not really a plot here but it's
just like a song about being like what
it's like to be on top of the world she
was on top of the world on Sunday and
she's using it to her Advantage like I
don't think it's a PR move but I think
all this attention you know today she
announced like the uh Eris tour movie is
actually not only going to be in the
United States it's being launched
globally so she's using this momentum
and she's a smart businesswoman for that
so I think Rising tides are rising all
shines and this is a good thing like
it's a good thing
I agree
hi do you think she'll be at the game
this weekend I have to get tickets to
the Jets game like mental note
I don't think so because I think she
would get really swarm because people
would be expecting her to be there yeah
but she like does spend like a lot of
her down time these days in her New York
City house right like maybe they'll hang
out in New York like maybe they'll go to
zero box oh my God I have to get dressed
and say alert you have to get dressed
insane every night this week I think
that they will be go they will be
spotted in New York together this week
after the game but what's like a
football player's schedule I don't think
like he just gets nights off like he's
in Kansas city until probably like
Thursday or Friday when's the game
I thought you said you're getting
tickets you don't know what it is no I
don't oh okay well after the game like
that night they would go out
that night okay
I have to go trust and say alert yeah
you should wear that sweater oh no don't
because that's Jets it's also eagles
which is giving Jason Kelsey yeah and
it's giving tailored
yeah yeah okay I'll wear red I don't own
a singular red item
go shopping even though I saw on Tick
Tock red is the color of like this
season they say
not for me
now for me either I don't own a single
piece I actually also don't think that's
true what would you say is the color of
the Season Jacks Brown
creams like Duty Brown
all shades of brown
cool light like up till nude you know
love the Spectrum
especially nude is brown
it's a diluted Brown
interesting
technically
is it not like a diluted white
no because there's color there's
there's a bit of color color is so crazy
like don't get me started I could like
color is just it's wild to me no I once
heard the craziest thing about colors
that I ca I don't even know if I'll be
able to explain again but it's like you
can't describe
a color right because you could say it's
kind of it looks like a rose but are we
seeing the same Rose yeah like how would
you describe the color red
you I would have to use other colors
therefore you know invalidating my
description no if you think too hard
about colors like you'll go mad yeah
somebody once said to me and honestly I
think it was Ben and I was like oh
that's such a dumb thing to say but
honestly it stuck with me and he was
right like how do we really know that
like when we you and I both say green
that we're seeing the same color
yeah
I
like I just I have to believe that we
are like I just have to believe it yeah
I have faith
yeah I have to have faith like we say
the sky is blue but how do I know like
the blue that you're seeing and I can't
describe the color so like how do I know
you're not seeing like green but like
you're calling it blue it's so true
colors crazy honestly I don't want to
talk about that anymore it's like
freaking yeah it is
okay ready for our next story yes I'm
excited to talk about this some more
football news Usher announces he will
headline the 2024 Super Bowl Halftime
Show With a Little Help from Kim
Kardashian oh yeah I'm sure we'll take
the stage for the iconic halftime show
presented by Apple music at the
Allegiant stadium in Paradise Nevada
during the big game on February 11 2024
so Las Vegas
um in a video shared on X he got an
urgent call from Kim Kardashian who
tells the musician about his
headlighting spot
it was a cute announcement I don't
really understand like Kim's involvement
I guess she's just like a big celebrity
and she loves
uh sure but like we should have had Kiki
Palmer in there just saying
um
I have so many thoughts my first thought
is
I think this is a great selection he
wouldn't have come to mind for me but
now that it's been brought to the table
I think it's great I think there's a lot
of people who maybe were a little bit
you know after Usher's time who are like
what this is random and I think they'll
be really pleasantly surprised by his
abilities and his talent and his songs
that they actually might know that that
sound actually really familiar to him
because when I when I saw it I was like
oh that's random I'm like actually it's
not and I think if you're at the level
where you can have a successful Vegas
residency you are automatically in the
running
four Super Bowl halftime show I think
it's great that it's in Vegas I think
it'll promote his residency a lot like I
think it's a great Synergy moment and I
actually think it'll be really good I
think it will be great he has so many
great songs he's such a showman he's a
great singer he's a great dancer and
it's going to be really fun yep he
probably would bring out guests I'm fine
if he does or if he doesn't same but I'm
really looking forward to this I think
it's going to be a fun moment it's going
to resurface so many great songs yeah
like if you really want more oh
man totally he better sing that I think
it's a really great a really really
great and not obvious choice you know
yeah which I like but then when I was
watching the game on Sunday before one
of the games started they had an
interview with uh Carrie Underwood
two of the hosts like the classic Fox on
Sports guys actually went to her
residency the night before because the
game they were always the Raiders game
they were in Vegas and they were talking
about a residency she was out here
promoting her residency she was talking
about how it's now been 11 years that
she's done oh Sunday and how much she
loves it and how she needs to
incorporate it into her residency it was
like a very cute interview and it got me
thinking like why why isn't Carrie
Underwood done it she has such close
ties to the NFL and she's also now a
residency Queen in Vegas this would have
been a good year for her to do it I'm
not unhappy with the selection but I'm
sure she was she was thought of I feel
like she's always thought of
unless there's a conflict because her
contract is with NBC yeah it's not that
she's so and also Apple music does the
halftime show so it's right it's not so
dry like oh NFL NFL football there
actually might be like a stipulation
where she's ineligible while she has
this contract and that because why
wouldn't she be pegged for it or the
people who are making the decisions for
the halftime show are not the same
people who made the decision to have her
sing the song for 11 years like maybe
they're not Carrie Underwood fans no but
if I was the person making the decision
for the Super Bowl I would take into
account that she's a kind of a fixture
in football culture yeah no they're not
taking it into account apparently
I just I I really like this Usher thing
and I think so many celebrities are such
big fans of Usher that's what I've seen
since his residency has popped off like
of course we know Keke Palmer Kim went
on the Kardashian show I think so many
celebrities like love him that there
might be a good amount of guests or
there just might be like a [__] ton of
celebrities who now want to go because
they love Usher yeah it's gonna be so
celeb studied even regardless of what
teams play because it's in Vegas it's so
close to La yeah that stadium is sick
like really sick it's gonna be crazy
yeah I kind of want to go I also think
they use the halftime show to capture
new audiences especially that's why they
brought in apple music like or I mean
yeah so they just paid a lot but um
Carrie Underwood's already in the Super
Bowl by singing the song true so it's
like true why don't we get new fans Also
let's talk about Kim's acting because
she did a little acting in that video
for Usher but her acting chops are being
spoken about quite
you know what's the word I'm looking for
extensively yes thank you so much
um because the first episode of her
American Horror Story show with Emma
Roberts the Ryan Murphy production
dropped last week I saw I basically
watched like 40 minutes of the episode
in two minutes Birds on Tick Tock and I
have to say Kim was excellent like she
has acted before she had like a small
part in like a bunch of movies where she
like plays as secretary I forget what
movie and like she was also in Nano 210
back in the day like she was bad she's
in Drop Dead Diva yes she had like a
small Cameo she obviously like took one
or two acting lessons and she wasn't
great it was giving you know actor like
I could tell she was acting and she has
a major role in this she's not doing a
cameo she's a major
star of the show I would say she's
probably the second biggest after Emma
Roberts and she took that [__] extremely
seriously and had to say she was
excellent in what I saw I haven't seen
anything from it she doesn't look like
Kim Kardashian trying to act she looks
like she plays this like high power
attorney publisher she really plays like
a Kris Jenner type and she's very good
good yeah like it's honestly
entertaining the show's concept is
really creepy I think like Emma Roberts
has like a demon inside of her while
she's pregnant I think that's like the
whole she gives birth to a spider I
don't [__] know
um so it's like creepy and weird and
that's not my style of TV show that I'd
normally watch but Kim is excellent
that's great even though I feel like
that's gonna mean that the next season
of Kardashians there focusing entirely
on how seriously she's taking the acting
process oh my God and they're gonna beat
it to death oh my God like SNL you're so
right like SNL oh my God and that was
one night
this is a whole season of a show
but the girl at least I've had a lot of
things going on actually recently
so between like Courtney's pregnancy
Kylie and Timothy Kendall and Bad Bunny
I actually think there's going to be
extensive fodder for the show for sure
but this might be Kim's thing yeah yeah
no it's so true
it's an amazing Point are you ready for
our next story oh I got it thanks around
more football news oh let's finish some
football news yeah and this will be
quick because Jets player's wife is
blasting
for sliding into her husband's DMS
that's us so Jersey Shore star Angelina
is being put on blast for sliding into a
married NFL player's Instagram DMS
Alexis bawden who's married to Jets
player Nick bodden took to tick tock on
Sunday to rip into Angelina for sending
her husband a DM that read quote see you
soon
yeah according to Alexis the message
arrived 10 minutes after she spotted
Snooki on the field at MetLife earlier
that day she said that she's never
watched Jersey Shore but she recognized
Snooki who was with another brunette uh
chick who looked like Angelina so she
saw her on the field and then she sent
that message she said that like Angelina
like clocked her like gave her an up and
down dirty look and she had her
husband's um number and last name like
all over her outfit in The Tick Tock she
showed her last his last name was like
on her pants the number was up here she
was like very clearly like she was here
you know with him and then she was like
and if you go to my husband's Instagram
it's literally pictures of me our
daughter me and my daughter him and my
daughter like it's a very he's not just
like you know right that to me is more
damning it's like you went to DM him and
you saw his page that he's a married man
yeah she called Angelina weird for
contacting Nick whose account contains a
plethora of photos as a family man she
said you don't message a married woman's
man that you're gonna see him soon after
you see his wife so then Angelina
bonded to this girl after she had posted
the tick tock and she said wow girl we
need to chat you coming at me on Tick
Tock acting like I tried to get husband
was very childish of you we all came in
support of your husband's team and his
teammates when I wrote to you soon I met
it in a nice mature way I'm an Engaged
woman I never in one million years try
to [__] get with your husband so take
the [__] Tick Tock down because you
look like a [__] idiot right now I
can't I came late I never saw you on the
field so I don't even know what the [__]
you're talking about that I saw you
looking all hot and [__] girl I wasn't
on the field nice try woman to woman if
you're secure in your relationship you
should know that as somebody else on
television I would never try to get rid
of married woman's man I'm engaged thank
you for your support sorry I didn't win
today sucks Alexis noted that she
thought Angelina like might have been
drunk because this message doesn't make
a ton of sense it's like the grammar
like everything sorry I didn't win today
sorry you didn't win today yeah or we
did win today and then she wrote back
Angela and her name's Angelina Angela I
don't really care how it happened I must
have missed thank you for another one of
your friends because you all look the
same but maybe just don't DM other
people's husband's weirdo
so yeah the on the field stuff is
speculation yeah it was her I'm less
concerned but like to DM a married man a
visibly married man and I see you soon
when you're engaged when you're engaged
it's [__] weird
it's weird it's bad behavior I'm sure
she was drunk and like acting a fool but
there's no excuse for it and I actually
I love that she called her out like you
can't do that [__] like you cannot act
that way with somebody like this is a
family yeah and why would she think that
she could like
see you soon
what no like actually this is like real
that's like what you say when you're
trying to like spark something inside
Swag Like It's like a poke you know duh
no this is really and then you would be
like oh things are coming out today yes
and I like that she got called out like
you can't act like this like and expect
no repercussions like this is what
happens when you [__] around and find
out I think and it's a good president to
set yeah like if you want to act this
way you may or may not be called out for
such Behavior now I know all athletes
have the reputation of being
philanderers but the fact that he got
this message and told his wife like yeah
I didn't look at his profile but the way
that she described his profile it's like
what did you expect no it was cute it
was like a lot of football a lot of
family like very you know very PG yeah
not really not the type of account you
slide into
exactly and it was like football family
and friends you know there's definitely
accounts you could slide into yeah some
games and you can make the case that
like unless you Google them you wouldn't
know that they're married based on their
100 100 and I and then I might sit here
and give someone the benefit of the
doubt and be like well maybe they didn't
know how are they to know they just
liked what they saw right
yeah not here no this is like so
embarrassing an open shut case
no I love this girl like it's so funny
maybe you'll see her if you go to the
game this weekend oh right she's on the
Jets I gotta go yeah are you ready for
our next story I think the better
question is are you ready for our next
story I I will be I know that I will be
soon
because today's episode is brought to
you by one of my favorite new sponsors
Braun and it was a very brawny weekend
here at my house with Harry being a bit
under the weather because we were
constantly taking his temperature now
the Braun thermometer has been a staple
during sixth season at my house it has
so many different amazing features that
really help mamas caretakers parents
everywhere Brown is a trusted 100 year
old brand with quality products that are
built to last Brawn ear thermometers are
clinically proven as accurate as rectal
so parents don't have to compromise
their comfort or baby's comfort for the
sake of accuracy yeah graduating from
rectal thermometer taking is a very
exciting day Ron is here to celebrate
with you but the thing about fevers is a
fever and a newborn can be more
concerning than a fever in the same
temperature in an adult or a toddler so
the fever threshold is lower Braun has
developed age Precision technology to
take the guesswork out the Braun
thermoscan 7 plus ear thermometer
provides age-based feed for Guidance
with a green yellow or red reading this
helps parents so they can understand the
severity of the fever based on the
child's age and they don't need to spend
time looking up information then you can
connect all that information to the
Braun Family Care app and the app is a
place where you can track temperature
readings log symptoms and medications so
you can keep track of your child's
progress and if you have multiple
children you can keep track of each of
theirs because it's a lot of information
to keep apart the app is a game changer
for those Middle of the Night Fever
episodes when you can't remember the
last time you gave a kid medicine and
now another child is sick now you can
keep everything together in one place
for the whole family
also the Braun thermometer comes with
those little plastic things that you put
on the end of it like to change out
every time you take a temperature I feel
like the school and there are some like
breaking around yes and it's super
sanitary so
visit Amazon search for bronze smart
thermometer and use code 20 toast at
checkout for 20 off your order so search
bronze smart thermometer at Amazon use
code 20 toast at checkout for 20 off of
your order
our episode is also brought to you by
papaya and Jackie I have an extremely
hot take for you are you ready yeah
I have found the perfect holiday gift
for literally everyone on your list it
will be their favorite thing that they
receive this year is it these reusable
paper towels from papaya our newest and
most amazing toe sponsor oh my God
you're quite literally Clairvoyant
because yes Jackie it is and before any
of you winches skip over this ad just
don't because one thing about me I've
always been a disposable paper towel
girly but the way that I was just
blowing through rolls of toilet paper
was not a good look for your garlic so
when papaya reached out to be a sponsor
of the show I was like okay let me let
me let me see let me see what's going on
and I have literally not touched a wall
of paper towel since I got them you uh
hpac comes with two of these reusable uh
towel paper towel sheets and one sheet
can replace 17 rolls of paper towel so
let's say I was babysitting Harry which
I would absolutely love to do anytime
you want to ask me to and he decided to
throw his entire cup of milk on the
floor which he might do because he's a
baby
instead of using half a roll of paper
towels to clean it up I would just use
my papaya rinse it in the sink and hang
it to dry on the papaya hook the way
that these papaya hooks are now hanging
all over my apartment is just giving
eco-friendly Queen energy I have one
hanging on the backsplash in my kitchen
one in the bathroom one by Theo's water
ball I put one by Harry's high chair for
such reasons as you discussed so it's
really giving versatility
I've been loving these giving them as
housewarming gifts dinner party gifts
they're just so cute and useful and it's
so much more unique than bringing a
bottle of wine so true and they also
come in garage's designs to match
whatever aesthetic you're going for I
love their kids collection for the boys
the designs are so cute and because the
founder of papaya is an actually huge
toaster she is giving fellow toasters 50
off the entire site we love toasters
supporting toasters so if you want to
try them out and trust us you do go to
papayreusables.com that's
p-a-p-a-y-a reusables
r-e-u-s-a-b-l-e-s.com and use code toast
for 50 off we just shaved years off your
life going to Costco and carrying jumbo
sized packs of paper towels home yet
welcome yeah welcome
our next story Jennifer Aiden and
Danielle Cabral get into physical
altercation and are suspended from real
houses of New Jersey so Jennifer and
Danielle have been suspended from the
real houses of New Jersey after getting
into an altercation while filming the
Bravo reality show page six can confirm
sources tell page six that the women got
into a heated exchange which then turned
physical during an event hosted by
Teresa on Thursday The Insider alleges
that quote Jennifer pushed in yell
during the argument and Danielle
retaliated by crumpling her plastic cup
and hurling and towards Jennifer's face
drawing blood however another source
plastic cup plastic cup yeah drawing
blood
if you crunch it and then there if
they're like yeah it's a red cup it gets
like a slice yeah however another source
assures us that Jennifer Aiden sustained
nothing more than a scratch wending yell
through her beverage even a scratch I'm
sorry like that's a cut yeah but
Jennifer pushed her yeah no no I'm
saying but they're trying to say like oh
no it was just yeah that's the same
thing a scratch is arguably a cut
surface was
puncture scratched punctured
um Jennifer does not receive medical
attention a separate production Insider
emphasized that Jennifer only pushed
Danielle because Danielle got in her
face page six is told both women are not
perfect permitted to film even alone as
the incident is under investigation
launched by Bravo and Sirens media the
production company behind Real
Housewives of New Jersey A source told
paycheck said the footage has been
reviewed to help determine whether
Danielle threw the plastic cup at
Jennifer or if she hit her while holding
it as incongruent accounts circulate
behind the scenes amid the ongoing
investigation uh well good thing it's
all on camera yeah and also I feel like
we've had many uh physical
altercations on across Housewives
franchise it's arguably some of the best
scenes
um and I don't know if I've ever heard
of two people getting suspended no so
that makes me think this is a bit bigger
than what they're describing because
shall I count the ways of all of the
physicality that we've seen like on even
even just on Jersey right Teresa pulling
Margaret the hair my name is Danielle
where is this what Teresa told her to do
it oh yeah yeah in my mind it's Teresa
playing Margaret's hair I mean it is
like theoretically yeah but well yeah
this like kind of makes no sense because
the way you describe it given you know
the varying degrees of Housewives fights
this doesn't sound like that crazy no
so it must have been suspended it must
have been crazy or then it must have
been crazy but also I find that these
two fighting confusing because alas we
saw on housewives Danielle was like came
in in my opinion like such loser energy
just wanting to be friends with Teresa
kind of like what Jennifer Aiden did
like she followed in Jennifer Aiden's
footsteps like just blindly joining that
couch because she thought it would give
her longevity on the show and yes it
ended up that like they kind of set her
up to fail and and remember she found
out the reunion that like they were the
ones
she they told her to bring up the thing
about Melissa but like they had already
told Melissa and she was like wow they
set me up so maybe that's why she kind
of flipped but because up until this
point her fighting with Jennifer Aiden
is like not Congress but what I know
about her on the show there's Discord on
that side of the couch now yeah it's so
crazy because I've really fallen off so
many Housewives just Bravo shows in
general but
I don't think I'll ever give up jersey
and I don't think I'll give up Beverly
Hills I'm up to date on Jersey Beverly
Hills uh I'm not watching Roni no
I'm not watching oh I'm pretty up to
date on Miami
of this season though no I'm halfway
through the last season and I never
picked it back up not up to date on OC
even though OC's been making news OC has
been making news and I haven't watched
but I kind of like love those ladies I
might I was thinking about watching it
again but I wanted more episodes to go
like to binge because I just filmed the
reunion I really enjoyed watching it
that way with New Jersey this past
season yeah week two week is not doing
it for me anymore no I'm not caught up
on Potomac
no oh my God me neither
which is which sucks because Potomac was
like really their Potomac has I think
the greatest housewife of all time Karen
yeah yeah like she just is she doesn't
try she just is yeah and I think a lot
of the other women on that franchise
like Giselle like I think she tries and
she's not yeah but I think that that
also the Gisele Karen Dynamic is like
we'll never get old because they will
never see eye to eye yeah but yeah but
it's not like any uh some of these
franchises like got bad so I stopped
watching but it's more so just like time
on my hands I think Atlanta I think
Atlanta got really bad I stopped
watching it because I was like this is
not good anymore but you know it was the
same with OC OC was really bad yeah but
you know what's back that I'm so excited
to get into because it's my comfort show
what southern charm
oh yeah I love Southern Charm I think
they're like two episodes and I'm gonna
watch this season because it's like one
of my favorite shows I don't know why I
just love it no and there's like a major
Scandal brewing in Charleston like The
Season's really slated to be like kind
of like their Scandal what's the Scandal
is it Taylor and Austin obsessed
no I know I know it's gonna make
everyone mad but it's been the
underlying thing throughout like it's
not right but it's okay
oh wow okay well I also don't think like
Shep is a sympathetic victim like right
the way in Scandal like Ariana has
always been just like a nice girl nobody
had any reason to dislike Ariana so when
she was wronged the whole fandom was
just rioting yeah but chip is kind of
like a uh polarizing character I don't
think people are gonna run to defend him
but also Taylor and Chet broke up
because like Shep couldn't rise like she
would have stayed with him if he could
have been the man that she needed it's
also messed up towards Olivia who's
friends right it's messy like it's just
messed up but yeah love wins I don't
even know what happens but I me neither
I ship
um are you ready for our fifth and final
story yes a little light happy love wins
news Bachelor in Paradise alums Kalyn
Miller keys and Dean ungler got married
this weekend in Colorado
wait this is such a throwback like
because when they got together like that
was the peak of us watching The Bachelor
and Bachelor in Paradise and that season
was really good who was he was in like a
love triangle with someone else Lombard
but then he was also like with Christina
oh yeah and I just I love Kailyn and
Dean I love them let me show like their
story and like how he came back for her
and what's so crazy is how opposite they
are or they yeah she's like glamazon he
like lives in a van no she's a pageant
Queen and he lives in a van like it
couldn't get more different yet they've
like melded their lives together and
they've made it work and I also feel
like she gives probably
um unrealistic hope to girls that like
men men can change I don't know yeah I
don't know who needs to hear this like
Kayla Miller Keys is the exception okay
it's not gonna happen to you she is the
exception it's so true that she was able
to turn into music he was a bad boy not
settling down like he left Paradise
because he liked her so much but like
couldn't commit to her right
and she changed him and that's just like
not gonna happen for you no it's so
unrealistic and it's like that's why we
all got so caught up in it because it's
really a fantasy and it's giving false
hope to millions of people around the
world and I just I think it's important
to remember like it's the exception it's
not the role yeah but I'm so happy for
her Mitchell she's also just like
literally the prettiest girl I've ever
seen in my life and he's so hot like you
just love to see how people out here
doing their thing yeah and I feel like
their aesthetic is very
um
country country but also like everything
that they do their pictures every like
it's all very aesthetic aesthetic and
and them and so their wedding was just
like a Pinterest Heaven yeah yeah they
had so many Bachelor people it was
really they've to me like represent like
the peak Bachelor years it was kind of
like the end of the peak yeah but they
were still you know a part of like the
very exciting time in the franchise and
so they're kind of like the last ones
we've been waiting on like Hannah G just
got married like they kind of it's
really like over
yeah well golden Bachelor premieres on
Thursday
oh that's kind of like I think gonna
change the landscape of media like
entirely no I think so too Zach and I
were watching a commercial and I was
like we're watching this oh you know
what else I've been weirdly wanting to
watch I've been seeing so many
commercials because Reba joined the
voice she replaced Blake Shelton so it's
Reba Niall Horan John Legend and Gwen
Stefani
um and I kind of like want to watch it
except every time I sit down to watch
The Voice it's like a two hour long show
and there's probably 11 minutes of
people singing and the other minutes are
commercials and like learning about
these people's hometowns and it's really
annoying like we we're tuning in to hear
people saying just saying yeah that
lineup that you described like doesn't
do it for me really I I like love Niall
Horan like on a personality level oh do
you I do and I love Reba
okay well I'm happy that you have that
speaking of Niall Horan like just
taking a leap and a jump and Back to
Football is do you know that Haley
Steinfeld and Josh Allen are very
serious like she was sitting in a box
with his parents at his game and of
course she was served by Taylor I know
but they've been together a long time
like we saw pictures of them like months
months ago but they're they're serious
like if you want a couple to root for
yeah that's really a couple you can get
behind yeah
it's really cute and no one's talking
about it enough
I agree but I think the fact that
they're not talking about it is like a
good thing yeah ultimately ultimately
for them but I just feel like this is
also exactly what we've been like
exactly like Taylor and Travis are well
suited very successful good looking
All-American
belt is so interesting to me
yeah honestly I don't know anyone who's
had a more strange career
she launched on the scene at the Oscars
because she was in some like Weird True
Grit yes oh my God you're a steel trap
thank you
and like that's how we found out about
her and then I think we all figured she
would like continue to be in like you
know Jessica Chastain types of movies
like well she was nine
no but we can we we figured she would
continue to be like a a sought after
high profile actress yeah she was she
did a couple big things like she did um
Edge of Seventeen I just happened to be
watching that the other day I loved that
movie oh no I I was just watching it her
character is infuriating infuriating but
I live for the best friend and the
brother yeah yeah that's what makes her
so terrible yeah
um Pitch Perfect well so before that
before Pitch Perfect and I think before
Edge of Seventeen she then had a pop
star era yeah where she was opening for
Katy Perry on the purism no no not what
came after prism Wonder on The Wonderful
World Tour witness thank you same
literally same thing witness World Tour
and she was like oh I guess she's
leading acting behind and she's gonna be
a pop star and then she just stopped
being a pop star and did movies again
and now we haven't heard from her like
honestly she has such a weird career
yeah but she's a very good actress
she's really like a triple threat she
excels at what she does yeah I feel like
I'm gonna check her IMDb Haley Steinfeld
movies but maybe now she just wants to
be a wag
um Dickinson is a show on Apple TV that
everyone's always talking about yes it's
like an old timey type of show
oh she was in a movie that I loved
called barely lethal with Dove Cameron
and Sophie Turner you guys should check
it out I think I've seen it I think you
actually made me watch it is it about
like a prom
it's there is a problem Incorporated
it's like CIA
um
undercover at high school you guys it's
good stuff and it's star studded Dove
Cameron hailee Steinfeld Sophie Turner
yes I remember watching this so good
this isn't the first time I've mentioned
that movie no it's not
so she just had like an interesting
trajectory
yeah Spider-Man
well that's a good money-making film I
don't know what kind of role she had but
oh there's a couple Spider-Mans here so
maybe that's where she's been and we
missed it because we don't know for sure
for sure that makes sense once you join
like a Marvel or DC Universe you might
be the biggest star in the world but the
two of us will never see you again no
that's so true I feel like that is kind
of what happened with Amber Heard like
she was a part of Marvel and like became
so famous like nobody really knew her
you know she was just an Aquaman right
yeah I think she might have been in
something else too but like once you're
there
you're like globally famous you're not
regionally famous yeah and you're you're
not toastily famous no because we don't
watch no that's what happened like with
Megan Fox for a while she was
Transformers but she was so famous
originally before that that like we kept
tabs on her yeah yeah
it's just like it really is this other
Stratosphere it's like another world
yeah and I don't get it whatsoever
me neither but it's not forever like not
everything will be for everyone and we
have Travis and Taylor and like that's
enough for us Diana
that's a beautiful note 10. you guys can
have Haley Steinfeld in the Marvel
Stratosphere yeah we'll take Taylor
well that's our show I feel so good I
had so much to say I feel like we said
it all I do feel like all of a said
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if your ass is
watching this on YouTube feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found that's
Spotify iTunes you know now defunct
Stitcher all the places I'm trying to
you know get creative but basically what
I'm trying to say is leave a review for
your girls like we work hard we could
use positive reviews we're stress to the
teeth yeah just talk about like how
beautiful studying wickedly talented and
smart we are like that's all you need to
write in the in the review five stars
thank you so much have a great day and
we'll see you tomorrow love ya bye